so thanks everybody really really
grateful for everyone coming
I'm Linda maze and the director of the
Child Study Center and I just want to
say on behalf of the Child Study Center
that all of us are so honored that
you've come out this morning to help us
celebrate this new space this new
building gives us the opportunity to
unite our programs that serve children
and families whether they be in the
clinical setting in the schools in the
community and to one integrated
collaborative space that sets the bridge
then seamlessly with our research space
at South frontage this space offers us
so much possibility for innovation and
discovery for learning from others and
also the possibility to integrate
seamless care to families wherever we
touch their lives now you join us after
we've been in our space now for about
two weeks we've been working we've been
seeing patients and we've been going
into the community from our new home
base we chose very intentionally to have
this invent in the morning because now
this is a working clinical as well as
research space and we wanted to respect
the needs of the families coming to us
and everyone doing their work by not
closing our practice during the busiest
times but rather actually to welcome you
in the early morning that we hope will
be filled with the energy of a new day
so we're very pleased as we settle into
this new working space to offer our
whole Child Study Center communities
thanks to you and also greetings to you
because it is now their space all of our
community space and we are welcoming you
into our new home but before we cut the
official ribbon we actually have many
many people to thank and we're going to
first turn to our colleagues
representing the many different ways
that the Child Study Center touches Yale
the School of Medicine the Yale New
Haven Health System the community our
state and beyond so first we'll hear
from Dean Robert Alpern of the Yale
School of Medicine speaking both for the
school and for Yale medicine then from
marna Borgstrom the chief executive
officer for the Yale New Haven Health
System speaking for the center's role in
Child and Adolescent behavioral health
across the health system Mayor Tony harp
joins us to speak at the to the sinners
place in the community and congresswoman
rosa DeLauro a longtime close and
honored friend of the centers joins us
to speak to the center's broad impact
then we'll hear from Aaron Warnock our
lead of clinical operations who will
speak to all of us who came together in
the Child Study Center community around
the space design and the move process
and then I will return at the end to
thank the many many people who have made
this new venture a reality so let me
first turn to Bob Thank You Linda so I
just want to comment on two things the
Child Study Center and then this
building so when I came here about
fifteen and a half years ago the one of
my first meetings was with Alan Kazdin
who was then the director of the Child
Study Center and he said to me he said
you probably don't know about us but you
should know that as Dean you will have
this incredible jewel of New Haven and
Connecticut in the country the Child
Study Center and it's interesting the
Child Study Center is probably unique
among all of our centers and departments
at the Medical School in that it does so
much more than just our typical missions
of research education and clinical care
they really provide social services that
they're for needy kids they they are
very active politically in trying to
express the voice of the children and
they they have so many different
services and they're there whenever any
catastrophe has occurred anywhere in the
state or further that affects children
and so it's really been a pleasure I
have to say I've spent most of my time
as Dean trying to truly understand the
scope of the Child Study Center
but someday I just also wanted to
comment on this building for those of
you who may know or don't know this was
a building that the telephone company
used for telephone lines and it had
almost no windows and it looked like a
bunker if there was ever a nuclear war
this was the building you wanted to be
in and when it was up for sale we had to
decide whether to buy it the the
location was just incredible so so we
just said how could we not buy this but
it was hard to imagine that it could be
turned into something that would look
really nice but the architects at the
school and people said you know we can
do this it will be really nice and so I
have to say coming here today
it did turn out really nice it matter
fact came out much nicer than I ever
thought it could come out so I guess I
won't take credit for knowing how nice
it was going to look but I think this is
incredible this will really be the home
that the Child Study Center has always
deserved thank you well thank you
Linda and I am honored to have been
asked to join you and Bob and I didn't
rehearse but I also just was thinking
about two thoughts I had about this one
is the relationship between the jelena
Haven Hospital in the health system and
the Yale University School of Medicine I
practically a fossil I've been here over
40 years and I remember doing the first
certificate of need for the inpatient
the first inpatient child psychiatry
unit and it was inpatient as the
hospital's purview outpatient is the
medical school so you do your thing and
we move on and how we've come together
as two organizations over the last
particularly 15 or 16 years that Bob
Alperin has been here and then how we've
integrated the Yale Child Study Center
not only clinically into this but how
has become such a leader on the
integration and you know our patients
see us as one organization and Linda has
been key to helping to lead this
transformation for the entire Medical
Center and so we owe her incredible
gratitude because I don't think we would
be here without her the second thing
that I just want to say is I think if
you talk to most of us who have spent
careers part of them are all of them in
health care and said what are the one
two big things that we have to deal with
in healthcare to try and reduce costs
and make health care less about sickness
and more about supporting people through
a continuum of life one of the two
things everybody would say is behavioral
health mental health it is at the root
of so many of the healthcare and public
health issues that we have and what has
really evolved in this Center will allow
us to do is to support more children and
families early on and intervene at times
in their lives when we can avoid some of
the problems that we have been seeing as
adults and we are putting mental health
people from the Child Study Center
together with our ambulatory pediatric
practices throughout the state so that
there isn't a make an appointment with
but the care team operates seamlessly
and I think this kind of investment is
also a key investment in a positive
trajectory in clinical care and in
public health so you know I salute the
Child Study Center thank you all for all
that you do and we're honored to be part
of it
thank you very much and good morning to
everybody it's really an honor and a
privilege to be here and what a great
space
I too was wondering where the windows
would be so I'm really very thankful
that spigot of a to bring some light
into this building because the work that
you do actually brings light into our
community and it really makes a huge
difference on behalf of so many children
in New Haven who often come to school
live their lives because they've been
impacted by trauma and other kinds of
things that most of us cannot imagine
but the work that you do here through
the work of dr. comer who was over there
who's actually helped to move our school
system forward we are so proud of our
relationship with that program and we
know that it's the reason that as you
look at urban areas in urban schools
ours is always ahead of the curve and
it's because of the great work that dr.
comer and his staff have done here but
they've taken it all over the United
States when I think about our police
force and what it is to be a police
person if you think about it they see us
at our worst and they also see that
there are children who see things at
their worst
that's because of Steven Marin's and the
work that's done here that our children
and our police officers have the tools
to go out and to deal with the kinds of
problems that young people have to face
in our community I worked for many years
when I was in the legislature with Paula
armbrister who was worked here for many
years and we were able to gather to make
sure that there were programs across our
city for our young people who are in
need so I don't know what we would do
without yell times child study I am so
grateful that you are here that you are
members of our community and that you
care about our kids and that you've
moved us forward as a city and I think
that you deserve space that reflects the
great work that you do and that the
children that come here deserve space
that lets them know that you respect
them that you have high expectations and
that they're going to be better because
they came here thank you for the
fantastic work that you do every single
day good morning and thank you all while
we're crowding into this beautiful
wonderful space here this morning and
what an honor for me to be here and I
just took just a little anecdote I
really feel very proprietary about Yale
Child Study because I'm very this goes
back a lot of years your AMA townie born
and raised in this city and at age two
now I don't remember this but it's been
passed down to me that my folks decided
that it was important for me to be
evaluated by the ghazal institution and
I just want you to know that they said I
performed I like aged four so I'm very
pleased to be associated with with an
institution that saw that I had I had
some promise so I I thank you all very
very very much true true story so to you
dr. Mason it's wonderful to be here with
them with all of you but dr. Mayes I
want to just say a thank you to you
under your leadership you continue to
improve the mental health of our
children our families this is an
extraordinary extraordinary Institute
and that you know that the integration
of clinical practice professional
training you transform the lives of
children and our families in this in
this space and Dean operand honored to
be with you and marna Mayor Aaron and
others I see in the corner there gene
add napo's who I've known for years who
has been a fixture at this at this at
this institution and I too wanted just a
a you know tip my hat to sev
people doctor meirin's has been
mentioned director of the National
Center for children exposed to violence
childhood violent trauma center Steve
and I have worked so closely together
over the years on tragic trauma
incidents whether it was 9/11 Columbine
Newton Newton most recently the with the
administration's family separation
policy on our southern border and Linda
we were together with dr. meirin's just
last June and it was and I had just
returned from the border it was my first
visit I'd been back several times but
both dr. baize dr. meirin's spoke about
the trauma of the separation of a child
from their family and it is in the more
you dig into what has happened there the
more in terms of your profession that
you are speaking out of what we have
done what we have done on our watch to
these children
which I have labeled actually
government-sponsored child abuse and we
should not be involved in government
sponsored child abuse to acknowledge
another trusted trusted friend and the
mayor mentioned dr. James comer my god a
friend a leader pioneer and education
child and adolescent development not
just in Connecticut but really all over
the world the coma model world renowned
you educate the whole child that's what
you do you don't where warehouse our
children and learned so much from dr.
comer and for me today is very special
to be a part of this ceremony and an
opening this is a wonderful beautiful
facility Wow
stunned I didn't know what I was
expecting but this is you know pretty
much out of sight to quote our kids it's
awesome guys it really is but what it is
it's not the bricks and mortar and right
and and you know and the space but it
really is the different areas of
expertise gathered here with a unified
goal
for the whole child and now you'll be
able to bring that together in one
facility Child Study Center cares for
3,000 families annually 60,000 clinical
visits per year while the visits are
scattered at three different sites
across New Haven this will improve this
facility will improve access enhancing
patient experience and promoting
clinical collaboration and while the
address changes Yale Child Study Center
remains as committed as ever to ensuring
every child has a chance to succeed
regardless of their family's financial
circumstances and you bring that level
of expertise and dedication to a range
of issues that's so often don't receive
that level of attention you have stood
up you've stood up for the principle
long before it became fashionable that
given the chance every child in America
can learn and can succeed so that's what
you will do and continue to do at this
facility you know study after study has
shown that the earliest childhood
experiences are essential and supportive
environments are critical for long term
outcomes for our kids for children to
thrive and our nation to stay
competitive we have to support their
development their families and their
health with public policies that make a
difference let me be personal for a
moment I grew up with in the Yale Child
Study Center you are so much a part of
who I am and my professional life and
experience you have really intertwined
for me my job my work was working with
children and families I have had the
opportunity and have been honored to
work with the
Giants of science of the whole child
your science has always been behind what
I can do and it has always informed what
I do and I think about it I know I I
won't mention everyone but dr. Albert's
sauna
Donald : who I first worked with when he
was you know it was a seven-day ward I
saw Israeli children with gas masks and
I picked up the phone and called Donald
and said these children must be
experienced unbelievable
trauma and he was engaged even volved
what was happening and he was just a
pioneer and what was happening to
children who witness violence have
talked about Jim calmer ed Ziegler was
associated the father of head start a
family resource centers I've talked
about Steve Myron's the mayor spoke
about community policing when you saw
those crusty burley law enforcement
folks sitting with clinicians and
figuring out what was going on and David
Hartman can attest to that - who works
with me this is it was reality for the
city of New Haven and and dr. Mayes
thank you thank you for what you are
doing to carry on this tradition and let
me just say I have today the honor of
chairing I know I'm going on but you've
got to understand you've got to
understand what you do and what
difference it makes I am blessed with
the opportunity to chair the
Appropriations Subcommittee on labor
Health Education and Human Services and
this year the House passed and
understand I am NOT talking about this
of being self-serving please but what we
did we passed a bill out that includes
two hundred and sixty million dollars
for social-emotional learning
initiatives to support the whole child
approach to education that we learned
that initiative initiative was inspired
by James comer we provided seven
dollars for the National Child traumatic
stress in this initiative
it improves behavioral health services
interventions for children and
adolescents exposed to traumatic events
that comes directly out of the the
network that we can fund and what we did
was we put in money specifically because
of the efforts that you have pointed out
of what is happening to children in
Puerto Rico what is happening to
children at the border with the the what
their are experienced and what is going
on with Native American children on
tribal lands you have brought all that
to light and when I think of at ziegler
it was important to say we need four
billion dollars to deal with early
childhood education and two-and-a-half
billion dollars for headstart
to help to make a difference for for our
kids again and I you know it I was able
with the help of folks here to establish
something called the bipartisan
congressional baby caucus that focuses
in on infants and toddlers that comes
out of what you have worked on and what
you have taught us and what is important
for us to spend our time our money and
our resources on that's where our
federal dollars should go mental health
services community schools all of these
efforts now I'm going to ask you as I
said I'm not doing this to be
self-serving please if you know me but
it is all of what you have shared with
me over the years of the direction that
this country should go in we are going
to begin to negotiate with the United
States Senate in a very short period of
time I'm going to fight for every dollar
but I'm asking every single person in
this room to fight with us so we
maintain the funding levels that we have
in the House bill yel Child Study is a
unique entity if you advance the
well-being of children in so many
different ways basic research genetic
neurobiological disorders you're trained
clinicians are
the world I can only say to you very
very personally thank you for what you
are doing you are transforming the lives
of our children you are working with
their families so that they can cope and
make their way and you are teaching
those of us who serve in public life
like the mayor and myself of what
direction our public policy initiatives
should should take thank you so so much
god bless you and I'm so honored to be
here with all of you thank you all so
much for joining us to celebrate the
opening of this space for those of you
who work with me closely you can
probably attest that I spend most of my
life completely amesh tin the details so
it is an absolute privilege today to
take as Eve people who know me so it's a
privilege today to really step back and
think about what this place means to the
center and it's so wonderful to hear
from the guests we've had here today
about what the Child Study Center truly
means to our local our state and our
national community there's just three
comments that I want to make to share
with the group that are really specific
to my experience in how we created this
space the first is a thank you to our
Child Study Center community this space
would not be what it is without the
energy the enthusiasm and the idea
generating potential of our teams we had
an amazingly dedicated space committee
on all of whom I hope are here today who
met for over three years to help think
about how do we create a space that
works for us thank you to those who made
time to participate in the community
workshops where we generated ideas we
planned we imagined how could we build a
space that really supports the work that
we're doing for our community and thank
you across the board to all the members
of our community who contributed ideas
big ideas little ideas as you walk
through the space you can see that all
of these ideas were incorporated into
the plans because each of them
made a difference and each of those
contributions served to create what this
space truly is today the second thing I
want to say because this has been my
experience in the past two weeks is to
express my thanks for everyone's
tireless work as we've actually moved
into this building and we have begun to
make it our own I have been in absolute
awe of the teamwork the flexibility the
positivity that I have observed as we
have been in the midst of this really
tremendous change for our community it
has been incredibly heartening in the
first few days we were in the building
on old friendships were being revived
people who had worked in different
locations for years but knew each other
five ten years ago were meeting in the
corridors and starting new conversations
and in the midst of that we also have
new friendships that are starting to
grow and all in part because together
we've created a space that really allows
us to come together in some very very
exciting ways and I want to end because
we need to say this I want to say thank
you to you Linda I think it's it's very
clear that this building is a result of
your vision without your support your
determination and the many many many
hours of hard work we would not be here
now so thank you for all that you've
done to make this a place where we can
all now flourish thank you
[Applause]
so thanks everyone
and we have a number of other people to
thank but I especially want to thank
Mara and Bob and the mayor and Rosa
really thank you for for helping us kick
this off as each of you highlights the
Child Study Center has just many many
roles in the school in yell medicine in
the health system the city our state
nationally internationally and we are
very proud as a department of our reach
and of our capacity but we also are very
aware that we have a responsibility
always be looking for ways to advance
knowledge to improve our practice to
educate the next generation and to shape
pilot policies that will positively
impact the health of children for
generations to come we actually take our
new tagline very seriously
we're discovery inspires care because it
underscores for us how we are striving
in our four missions for to care for
families to care for each other and for
all of those who will follow us so this
building actually reflects the care as
Aaron has said also of just a tremendous
number of people in teams and if you
will just have just a tiny bit more
patience before you tour the space we
actually want to be sure they
acknowledge them so first from absolute
start to finish until the last box was
moved and even thereafter
and all the tales that followed in
unpacking and settling in it would not
have been possible without the efforts
of Aaron whom you've heard from
and it also would not have been possible
without the efforts of Ian Solomon our
Director of Finance I don't know where
it is but he's somewhere where they're
good idea we are they have both
accumulated so many hours they have
walked so many miles they've actually
been counting the steps and they've
touched with so many people during this
effort we are all very grateful to both
of you and none so grateful as I thank
you in the days leading up to the move
actually during the unpacking it was a
remarkable d-day was not better
coordinated and in the days of settling
in we're actually very grateful to
Bethenny Klein who is the coordinator of
our in-home services who volunteered
Bethany room Bethany volunteered her
time and support and on the move weekend
was here late hours and helping with
unpacking and went well beyond the call
this entire project however would not
have been made possible was made
possible would not have been possible
without the support of the Yale Medicine
board with all my fellow chairs we have
a great stories to tell about how that
happened Paul to Harry the deputy Dean
and chief executive officer of Yale
Medicine and Gary dizzier the chair of
internal medicine and chair of the Yale
medicine board and also Fred Borelli of
Yale Medicine who tirelessly championed
this project we're extraordinarily
grateful to all of you in your medicine
for your commitment to child behavioral
health for your recognizing that it is
central to having an integrated practice
across the school to have child
behavioral health and for helping us
create a space that conveys the respect
that we hold for the families who come
to us with Inyo medicine mr. Yale
facilities team that includes Robin or
Kellyanne Werth Karen Lee Terry and
Bruce McCann who interface patient with
us patiently with us and the
architectural team to bring us to a
completed project that let us say fits
within yellow standards
but at the same time set a new bar let
us say for clinical aesthetics and
presentation so the bar is now high
spiegel's and partners our architectural
colleagues are around I know they're
passing out beautiful cards that I want
you to see they designed this space with
a care not only for our clinical and
work sensibilities but also a need to
have a space that was friendly to
children but not child like a space that
conveyed respect and calm and openness
to possibilities and one that encourages
us to all come together and work and
learn from one another so Lynne Bratton
Rotman Bryanston cabbage and Chris Bach
stole from speaks fecal they generously
included and listened as you've heard
from Erin to our Child Study Center
community incorporated their suggestions
as often as they could and they gave us
a space that actually exceeds our
imagination that it came out of their
imagination standard builders I hope our
standard builder team is around took
spiegel's design into execution and
we're very grateful to the standard team
that includes michael iveco lee jeff
libby perry Finelli eric credo and brian
Bachus they welcomed all of us
well not everybody but a substantial
number of us into their construction
meetings
they were incredibly patient with all of
our questions they really listened they
made the whole process actually
remarkably fun and truthfully we're
missing the Wednesday morning
construction meetings as with all of our
spiegel's team the standard team will
always move a member of our Child Study
Center community and we're very sure we
want to be sure that they will always
wear their Child Study Center team cap
and be a part of the team and we hope
that we can work on many projects with
them hence holding our team together the
Yale team and standard builders together
as a working group was Mary Ann and Mary
Ann Cleveland is Mary Ann here you just
should know that Mary Ann is patient
responsive and has a remarkable sense of
humor even when we continue to bring up
more complications Nancy Simotas was the
art consultant and brought the finishing
touches to this space design I hope you
will look at the art I hope you will
look at the plaques that also designate
the artists she had the remarkable
ability and patience to steer us toward
an aesthetic even that was a unified one
even with multiple different inputs and
she also if you hope you will read was
able to engage a number of young artists
just starting out in their work and to
bring their work into this building
which is very meaningful to us as a
developmental Department we're grateful
to Jim Stockwell director of the
communication design and Lena Smith
Parker director of operations in the
Yale School of Medicine office of
communication for their work on our logo
our new logo and ensuring that we have a
coherent and engaging updated visual
presentation that captures the growth of
the center now there's so many others
that have made this large endeavor
possible from Laura Bennett weinstein
from LMB design our move coordinator who
made it possible to move 220 people in
36 hours in relative order and
predictability and with nothing lost and
the many people from IT who worked
actually through the evenings to set up
the tons of computers in this space the
telephones across the university and
hospital systems working together
seamlessly across and so many others who
joined in it's not just to move that
reflects the team working together but
it's a shared mission on the whole
project
the Child Study Center space committee
engaged with every detail as you've
heard and we also want to bring very
much thanks to Michael hep
wherever Michael is who brought this
this reception together in his reign
helped us arrange this event in his
customary but still very understated and
really confident and thorough way and to
Mary whose team as well in the
Communications Office and Michael and
Mary you are also a part of our team you
get the team cap so finally there are
two very very special gifts that we need
to acknowledge and want to acknowledge
two very special donors
the first is scholastic publishers with
whom we established the Yale Child Study
Center scholastic collaborative in
February of of 2019
scholastic has generously donated books
for our two book nooks which I hope you
will see at the end of Main Street
they've given a book vending machine
which most of us actually didn't even
know existed but a book vending machine
and also a beautiful display in our
waiting room of art and writing from
adolescents that are a part of the
annual scholastic arts and Writing
Awards there are many many good
colleagues from scholastic who are here
this morning included including dick
Robinson the president of scholastic and
we're so grateful for this partnership
and scholastics overall generosity
toward children and families not only
that we serve but children and families
across the world
and so we look forward to all that we're
going to do and have already done
together with scholastic to make the
world a better place for children
our second gift brings this event in the
child study centers history full circle
the first director of the Child Study
Center was dr. Arnold gazelle a
pediatrician and psychologist hence the
Gazelle Institute
he led the way in the early discoveries
about child development as our founding
director and he devoted his career to
Yale he shaped much of the basic
understanding about children's and
children's development the ghazal family
has remained Friends of the center since
the earliest days of its founding in
1911 and Rex Walden
dr. gazelles grandson a painter and a
teacher has created two original works
for our building and that in the Kremlin
in the creation and donation capture not
only the devotion of the gazelle family
to Yale but also in the spirit of where
discovery inspires care so I'm
personally extremely grateful to Rex and
to his family and including his mother
Tassie and his father Joe with whom I
was very close friends and we're very
sure that Tassie and Joe are in this
room right now and they would be Tassie
would be so proud Rex especially of your
creativity and that it is present here
so we're very proud to let you see and
show you Rex's work and to honor the
enduring lengths of his family with the
Child Study Center
so in closing let me express again my
thanks to all of you for coming to all
of my colleagues at the Child Study
Center for all you do for children and
families and to everyone who has made
this new space possible the poet Wendell
Berry reminds us of the important of
place grounded in caring when he rights
belong to your place by the knowledge of
the others who your neighbors in it in
the old man in the sick in the poor and
by your caring for it as you care for no
other place this place this space has
already profoundly impacted all of us
who are working in it and in how we see
ourselves in this community and in with
the families who seek our care we hope
that you will enjoy seeing this space as
much as we are now enjoying living in it
and you will also join with us and
imagining how we can use this new
opportunity in this new place to provide
the best care informed by the best
science for
the children and families that seek our
help so now let's get to the
ribbon-cutting and we after that we will
invite you to walk through the space we
have Aaron has thoughtfully provided
highlighted maps so you have a guided
tour and you will have members of our
Child Study Center community that are
sitting at the or standing of those
stations who are really really eager now
to tell you about their home our home so
may I ask the speakers as well as Ian
Solomon Paul - Harry and Gary de xira
piece here to come forward to cut the
ribbon with us
[Laughter]
the psych department
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]